at a purpose-built Air Terminal on the
outskirts of Paris a glimpse at what
could be the future of taxi services the
german-built follow copters of vertical
takeoff and Landing drone that's big
enough to carry passengers
idea is it'll be open to the full
community anyone that wants to take an
Uber today there's no reason why they
shouldn't contemplate taking Ebola city
across across an urban urban landscape
or across the city for um to get for me
to be a lot quicker Paris transport
officials plan to have two operational
volocopter routes for the 2024 Olympics
as the aircraft are fully electric and
quieter than a helicopter they say that
then ecological alternative to
fuel-powered vehicles
well it's only very comfortable and
spacious here at the moment there is
room for a passenger and a pilot but the
manufacturer of helicopter says that in
the future this service could be pilot
free
several cities in the world are testing
similar aircraft as competition steps up
in a potentially multi-billion dollar
market once we have started in mass
production it will be definitely
available for everyone so also the
Affairs will go down over time and we
will definitely see it all over the
world for now fares are expected to be
around a hundred US dollars for a short
ride a price few Ordinary People could
afford yes I would say it's a Ultra
niche market of course you always have
some rich people wanting to saving some
time but I think it won't be the Uber of
Tomorrow Air Taxi definitely it's for a
target language of customers
it's unlikely that flying taxis will
replace regular cabs anytime soon but in
a city where heavy traffic is common
some will certainly welcome the chance
to skip the bottlenecks on the ground to
gain precious time in the air
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Sergi pontois
[Music]